el secretario de estado Anthony bling
kenne tenía planeado viajar a China a
principios de la próxima semana para
tratar de mejorar las relaciones
bilaterales pero su viaje fue pospuesto
el globo chino sigue sobrevolando
espacio aéreo estadounidense después de
haber pasado por Alaska y Canadá que
también reaccionó a través de un
comunicado alertando que otros globos
chinos pueden presentarse en un futuro
para acceder a información confidencial
situación parecida con otros globos
chinos ya se había presentado en Hawaii
y onolulu China al respecto reaccionó
diciendo que lamentaba lo ocurrido y que
el globo se había desviado en su
investigación climática la última vez
que este globo fue visto en Estados
Unidos fue en el estado de Montana y a
pesar de haber considerado derivarlo el
comandante en jefe de las fuerzas
armadas de Estados Unidos y el General
Kelly recomendó no hacerlo para evitar
que restos generaran peores daños en
tierra el espacio aéreo de Montana
estuvo cerrado por algunas horas y el
departamento de defensa no revelar
exactamente En dónde está el globo
actualmente Pero dijo que el riesgo de
robo de información confidencial está
controlado y que se estudia la mejor
manera de contrarrestar la presencia de
este globo el hecho ocurre precisamente
también cuando estén Secretario de
Defensa estadounidense anuncia desde
filipinas que Estados Unidos aumentará
la presión la presión y la presencia
militar en bases militares de Filipinas
para hacer frente a la amenaza creciente
de china en esa región